avec nous le politologue Pascal
Perrineau bonjour Pascal on est ravi de
vous revoir dans ce club et le sondeur
Emmanuel Rivière bonjour Emmanuel
directeur international des études
politiques pour quantard public on va
parler si évidemment et de retour le
journal ici va être revenu on parlera
avec vous de la réforme des retraites
jour de commission mixte parité à la
réunion des députés des sénateurs pour
trouver un accord sur ce texte qui
pourrait bien déterminer si le
gouvernement devra ou non en passer par
le 49-3 l'Assemblée nationale on verra
ça avec vous et Elisabeth borde
joue-t-elle son avenir dans ses
prochaines 48 heures elle tente de
convaincre les députés de droites
réticents le rassurant qu'un vote de la
réforme ne vaut pas soutien au
gouvernement on parle de tout ça d'abord
on regarde l'actualité dans nos régions
ces journées de mobilisation
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Montpellier retrouver Olivier Biscay
bonjour Olivier merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeurs des rédactions du
Midi Libre Olivier comment s'annonce
cette huitième journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
des manifestations des grèves des
ralentissements voilà à quoi ressemblera
le cocktail social ici en Occitanie des
manifestations à Montpellier à Perpignan
à Nîmes les syndicats évidemment les
experts plus fournis que samedi comme
partout en France ou le nombre de
manifestants étaient plus faibles qu'à
l'habitude des grèves dans les
transports essentiellement on le verra à
7 à Montpellier et dans certaines
administrations de de la région et puis
après de nombreux appels au mouvement à
la veille du vote à l'Assemblée
nationale
et du et du débat par les organisations
syndicales donc évidemment ce qui sera
retenu cet après-midi c'est le nombre de
manifestants et l'énergie portée par les
opposants à la réforme des retraites
dans chacune de ces villes qui ont été
fortement marquées ces dernières
semaines vous le savez par une grande
mobilisation notamment à Montpellier et
dans les villes moyennes dans l'Aveyron
la Lozère et dans les Cévennes et
Olivier vous intéressez aussi aux élus
du côté des élus est-ce que les choses
sont claires est-ce que les uns et les
autres savent s'ils vont voter on passe
à très fort du côté de la France
insoumise et du Parti socialiste
tendance nuque c'est assez clair
évidemment ils sont totalement opposés à
la réforme de retraite et ils sont en
ligne dans nos départements où c'est que
dans l'Hérault et dans le Gard les
députés les filles sont très nombreux
notamment à Montpellier et à Béziers du
côté du rassemblement national la
tendance est totalement
identique c'est du côté probablement de
renaissance qu'il faudra trouver des
nuances du côté de Patrick Vignal
notamment qui depuis trois ou quatre
jours et totalement silencieux
d'ailleurs son groupe lui a demandé de
se taire littéralement parce que il a
indiqué dans nos colonnes dans Midi
Libre qui hésitaient encore à voter
cette réforme considérant que le
gouvernement n'était pas allé assez loin
de manière globale Renaissance ils sont
moins nombreux qu'il y a 5 ans seront
sur la ligne de la de la réforme des
retraites c'est là que ça se jouera du
côté Patrick Vignal et on attend dans
les prochaines heures il devrait
s'exprimer normalement avant demain sur
son intention de voter la réforme
considérant peut-être le gouvernement
aura fait les efforts nécessaires pour
le pour le convaincre et on les réa
évidemment tout ça dans le Midi Libre
merci beaucoup Olivier Biscaye on
regarde vos deux une la Une de
Montpellier Lunel Montpellier
architecture l'audace des prochaines
folies et la haute la une du reste de
l'Occitanie se sont ces records
d'éclairs qui sont à lire aujourd'hui
dans le Midi Libre merci beaucoup
Olivier Biscaye d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler de cette mobilisation 8e
journée de mobilisation on a vu que
celle de samedi a été un peu moins de
est-ce que ça veut dire parce qu'elle
que les Français sont résignés ou est-ce
qu'au contraire la mobilisation peut
rebondir aujourd'hui jour de commission
d'expérience les Français quand on
regarde les sondages d'opinion ils sont
résignés depuis le début
c'est-à-dire que voilà une majorité
considère que voilà la réforme n'est
vraiment pas n'est vraiment pas à
soutenir mais en même temps que à la fin
des fins et bien cette réforme sera
votée et sera appliquée et là on est aux
alentours de plus de 70% des personnes
interrogées qui pensent cela donc la
résignation
elle est là les signes de la
mobilisation tout même les premiers
signes maintenant sont des signes plutôt
d'affaiblissement de la mobilisation à
la fois en termes de personnes
mobilisées dans les rues même si en
effet la mobilisation reste à un niveau
élevé quand on compare cette
mobilisation mobilisation et au
mouvement sociaux comme on dit du passé
on s'aperçoit en effet qu'on est plutôt
dans le haut de la fourchette et en
termes de grève on le voyait ce matin
par exemple dans l'agglomération
parisienne les grèves dans les
transports ne sont pas au niveau des
espérances syndicales donc il y a des
signes un peu d'essoufflement du
mouvement on est dans une forme de
paradoxe chez les français Emmanuel à la
fois ils sont opposés à cette réforme
mais à la fois ils en tout cas c'est ce
que disent l'opinion vous allez nous
confirmer que finalement elle finira par
aboutir oui c'est ce que rappelait
Pascal à l'instant et même sur les
toutes récentes enquêtes on atteint un
niveau en hausse de la proportion de
Français qui disent de toute façon ça va
se faire c'est pour ça que les jours à
venir sont assez cruciaux ce que s'il y
a une adoption
demain à l'Assemblée nationale
définitive du texte quel qu'en soit la
forme d'ailleurs
voilà ça peut avoir comme message aux
Français que bon bah il n'est pas
forcément nécessaire de poursuivre et on
voit que pour l'instant ça a tenu
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un très léger
raffaissement du soutien en mouvement
mais qui reste majoritaire on a en gros
les deux tiers des Français qui sont
contre la réforme et qui pensent que le
mouvement social doit perdurer puis à
cela s'ajoute que si et donc il reste un
petit suspense comme votre interview
avec le ministre du soft a montré le
mouvement et le texte était adopté par
un vote avec une majorité on sait que
certaines organisations syndicales CFDT
en tête on dit on en prendra acte donc
évidemment que dans l'avenir du
mouvement tout cela va avoir un impact
ça veut dire il y a deux choses dans ce
que vous dites d'abord est-ce que ça
veut dire que le mouvement peut changer
de forme parce Pascal est-ce que ça veut
dire que là vont rester les plus
radicalisés on va insister un mouvement
qui peut tradicaliser alors tout dépend
comme vient de le dire Emmanuel Rivière
de l'issue sièges et le 49,3 bien sûr
le mouvement et les leaders de mouvement
considéront qu'il y a là une forme de
brutalisation
et les choses ne se passeront pas aussi
facilement que s'il y a un vote en bonne
et due forme ce que Olivier Dussault
tout à l'heure appelait de ses vœux en
effet
leader de la CFDT c'est important c'est
de le premier syndicat français
aujourd'hui le dire de la CDT a dit
voilà c'est pas notre tasse de thé mais
on en prendra acte donc ça veut dire à
ce moment-là que le front syndical qui
jusque alors était unie un front divisé
et qu'il y aura en effet des radicaux
qui éventuellement peuvent tenter de se
radicaliser ça pourra pas durer très
très longtemps et de l'autre côté ce
qu'on appelle traditionnellement des
syndicats réformistes qui se plieront à
la loi commune voter par le Parlement ça
veut dire que ce qui va se décider
demain au Parlement risque fortement de
fissurer le front syndical oui davantage
le France syndical que le l'opinion
publique parce que finalement ça change
pas grand chose on est aussi dans une
situation de tension ou une majorité des
Français non seulement sont contre la
réforme mais je pense qu'on a un niveau
d'intérêt très élevé sur cette question
et d'ailleurs on a un niveau d'intérêt
pour la politique qui ne se dément pas
qui contrairement à l'habitude ne
faiblit pas depuis les élections
présidentielles législatives
c'est-à-dire que non seulement les
Français sont contre la réforme et ils
savent que le pays est contre la réforme
et donc sa chance là ils se disent le
gouvernement va et le président de la
République va aller au bout et
le 49-3 effectivement aurait un effet
tout à fait spécifique sur les acteurs
et notamment les organisations
syndicales le fait de pas passer au 49 3
changerait pas grand chose du point de
vue de l'opinion publique de toute façon
il se diront pas 4 peu importe pour eux
c'est une approcher durant parce que le
43 une très mauvaise réputation et
signalera encore plus un sentiment de
passage en force il faut pas se faire
d'illusion c'est pas parce que ce sera
voté par une majorité de députés que les
gens n'auront pas le sentiment qu'on a
adopté une réforme contre ce qui leur
souhait et contre le souhait collectif
alors ça ne change pas beaucoup quand
vous regardez les précédents mouvements
de réforme des retraites
l'opinion a toujours été peu ouprou
opposé à ces différents mouvements de
réforme qui ont commencé en 1993 avec la
réforme Balladur et ce sont poursuivis à
la fois sous la droite et sous la gauche
donc il y a toujours eu une opinion qui
était une opinion qui était défavorable
au mouvement de réforme des retraites
mais une fois que la représentation
nationale s'est prononcée et bien voilà
on met sa déception dans sa poche et on
continue alors quand s'exprimera
éventuellement le retour du refoulé le
retour de en colère et bien on verra si
en particulier aux élections sur
démocratie parlementaire contre
démocratie sociale pour vous la
démocratie parlementaire
pourra sur la démocratie sociale et
heureusement dans un état de droit si
vous voulez qui a la légitimité c'est la
démocratie représentative c'est très
important la démocratie de la rue les
manifestations les autres expressions de
la démocratie la démocratie
participative etc mais à la fin des fins
dans un état de droit et dans une
démocratie digne de ce nom c'est voilà
le pouvoir représentatif à savoir le
Parlement qui vote la loi la loi commune
à tous les Français
alors dans l'historique des moments de
retraite il y a quand même différence
scénarios et le scénario de 2003 par
exemple avec un mouvement social
également très dur une réforme qui a été
entérinée et qui a d'ailleurs plutôt
servi d'image du gouvernement du
gouvernement Raffarin et quand même une
nuance de taille c'est qu'une
organisation syndicale la CFDT avait
soutenu la réforme et décrocher quelque
chose de significatif là ce qui est un
peu spécifique dans la en fait ce qui a
été le plus important aux yeux des
Français étaient entériné dès le départ
c'est le passage de 65 à 64 dans cette
réforme il faut avoir en tête que ceux
qui focalisent l'attention c'est la
mesure d'âge et le report de l'âge et
c'est peut-être ça qui va rester c'est
un sentiment d'absence de dialogue quand
bien même il y a eu des discussions
préalables avec les partenaires sociaux
des discussions avec les républicains là
on a un peu le sentiment d'un défaut
d'écoute et qui a été un peu d'ailleurs
illustré peut-être non sans habilité par
cette demande des syndicats d'être reçus
par le Président de la République qui
s'est vu opposer une femme non recevoir
en renvoyant vers le ministre du Travail
cette idée d'un dialogue direct entre le
président et les organisations
syndicales était très soutenu aussi dans
l'opinion donc il pourrait y avoir cette
trace là qui n'était pas forcément dans
d'autres réformes des retraites non
seulement être allé au bout de la
réforme mais avec un défaut d'écoute au
passage on va reparler allez-y Pascal on
va voir ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
c'est à dire la commission mixte
paritaire si vous faites la transmission
spatiale il va y avoir des négociations
et quand on écoutait attentivement
Olivier Dussault tout à l'heure on
pouvait se dire que sur certains
éléments de la réforme ils pouvaient la
majorité pouvait lâcher quelque chose on
s'aperçoit d'une certaine souplesse dans
la dernière ligne droite de la part du
gouvernement on va parler de cette CMP
on va parler du 49-3 puisque de ce qui
sort de la CMP peut-être ce jour à le 49
3 ou pas d'abord si on va faire un point
avec vous c'est MP alors on commence à
se faire exactement quels sont les
textes qu'il encades alors la commission
mixparitaire elle est prévue à l'article
45 de la Constitution en ce qui concerne
ces modalités pratiques en matière de ce
de fonctionnement il faut se référer à
une réunion de
1959 qui a réuni les secrétaires des
deux assemblées et du gouvernement
réunion qui a débouché sur un procès
verbal qui a ensuite été intégré dans
les règlements de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat alors qui participe
physiquement qui a le on l'a déjà
beaucoup dit un 7 députés 7 sénateurs
mais aussi et on l'oublie souvent un
certain nombre des lits peuvent
physiquement être présent pendant la
réunion les appels les suppléants ils
sont 7 députés suppléant cette sénateurs
suppléant ils ont droit de prendre la
parole mais ils ne votent pas au moment
de l'examen des concluants des
conclusions juste un petit détail parmi
les suppléants il y aura une certaine
sonnerie de Rousseau SNCB donc ça promet
d'être assez mouvement ils seront ils
seront 28 dans la salle parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de 14 ils seront 28 alors
est-ce qu'une commission d'expéritaire
peut toucher à tous les articles par
exemple l'article induit taxi régime se
fait sur alors on va ressortir parce
qu'elle me regarde avec des Français
l'article 45 de la Constitution qui nous
dit que l'objet de la réunion d'une CMP
est de proposer un texte sur les
dispositions restantes en discussion
c'est-à-dire en fait celles qui n'ont
pas été adoptées dans les mêmes termes
par l'une et l'autre assemblée là pour
le coup des choses sont plutôt simples
puisque à l'Assemblée nationale et ce
sont arrêtés à l'article 2 qui a été
rejeté donc deux articles sur 120
l'article j'ai dit quoi 120
articles sur 20 l'article 7 précisément
sur les 64 ans n'a même pas été examiné
donc en résumé oui là CMP d'aujourd’hui
va pouvoir toucher à tous les articles
puisque aucun article n'a été adopté
dans les mêmes termes à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat et alors l'autre
question qui s'est posée c'est que
finalement cette CMP ne sera pas ouverte
aux caméras la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a refusé la demande des
députés de gauche qui était de
retransmettre la Réunion est-ce que
c'est interdit
mais c'est pas prévu donc voilà je vous
fais une réponse un peu de Normand il y
a LeBron Pivet habilement utilisé les
termes du règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale pour écarter la demande de la
gauche dans un courrier qu'elle a envoyé
au député socialiste Boris Vallot elle
se réfère à l'article 112 alinéa 3 qui
renvoie lui-même qui renvoie lui à la
Linéa 3 de l'article 46 on peut y lire à
cet article la chose suivante à l'issue
de
comme ça ça n'aurait pas été de rigueur
parce qu'à ou est-ce que pour la
sérénité des débats il faut que cette
réunion se tienne avec non qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une CNP ça cherche à mettre
d'accord les deux assemblées bien
cette CMP il faut savoir que c'est
utilisé fréquemment et que dans deux
tiers des cas ça aboutit à un compromis
et on ne peut que s'en réjouir la
démocratie c'est le compromis c'est
aller vers l'autre qui n'est pas un
ennemi qui est un adversaire avec elle
on cherche à trouver un terrain
d'entente c'est ce qui va se passer ce
qui est en train de se passer dans cette
commission mixe paritaire ça ne peut se
faire que loin des caméras est loin des
micros le sujet d'abord est un sujet
extrêmement technique
il y a eu un débat énorme on l'a vu au
Sénat plus de 100 heures de débats on
l'a vu à l'Assemblée nationale il faut
maintenant aller vers une solution de
convergence et on a besoin d'une
certaine discrétion si vous voulez la
transparence à tout prix qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'est-ce que ça cache
d'ailleurs souvent ça cache un désaccord
avec les institutions démocratiques et
on le voit bien de la part de et les
filles et les filles cherchent
souvenez-vous à bordéliser l'Assemblée
nationale bien là on cherche à
bordéliser la commission mixte paritaire
qui est un élément essentiel de la
création du consensus parlementaire
c'est ça il y a une volonté de chercher
à bordéliser une volonté sincère de
transparence non mais on est dans un
contexte où je crains qu'on aille un peu
dans l'aggravation d'un problème de fond
qui est
l'appropriation par les Français de la
qualité d'importance du travail par le
mental pourquoi est-ce que parmi les
démocratie européenne on est une un des
pays où le taux de participation aux
élections législatives ce sont les plus
faibles parce que beaucoup de Français
ont le sentiment qu'en fait il ne se
produit pas grand chose et lorsqu'on
interroge les Français à l'aube des
législatives 2022 sur leur mémoire de la
législature précédente ce qui s'était
passé ils étaient très en peine de citer
quelques grands textes qui avaient été
discutés donc on a l'impression que tout
procède de l'exécutif il y en a un vrai
besoin de d'une part de restaurer la
réalité dans sa perception de la
séparation des pouvoirs et de mieux
rendre compte du travail parlementaire
et c'est pas du tout ce qui est en train
de se passer sur les derniers mois on a
plutôt l'impression que
devenu un théâtre non plus un théâtre
d'ombre mais un théâtre de lumière
criards de désagréable et
voilà le constat d'un éloignement avec
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée nationale
sans doute davantage que Sénat je dis
pas ça parce qu'on est sur Public Sénat
et le problème et ça pose un problème en
retour de de légitimité c'est pour ça
qu'on doit aussi se poser la question de
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand les
Français se disent bon ils veulent faire
la retraite à 64 ans au bout du bout et
à la retraite à 65 ans et quand est-ce
qu'il y aura été modifié du texte
c'est-à-dire des choses très important
de côté modifier risque de passer un peu
sous le radar et justement est-ce que de
l'issue de cette commission mixparitaire
dépend l'utilisation du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale bien sûr parce que
si par exemple imaginons qu'aujourd'hui
des compromis de la part de la majorité
soit soit fait que en effet
Renaissance arrive à élargir sa base et
se disent bon sur ce texte ça va être
difficile aux quelques rép réticents ou
même au réticent en interne de la
majorité de continuer leur fronde à ce
moment-là on aura un texte présenté et
un vote peut-être un vote ricraque mais
un vote du projet 6 ça n'est pas le cas
se posera bien sûr la question mais là
aussi dans l'histoire de la 5e
République c'est un grand classique la
question de l'utilisation de l'article
49 à Linéa 3 ou le texte sera adopté
sans être réellement voté puisqu'on
attendra c'est la logique de l'article
49 alinéa 3 une motion de censure donc
bien sûr on le voyait en écoutant
Olivier Dussault tout à l'heure du moins
on l'entendait le gouvernement aimerait
bien éviter cela mais s'il y est
contraint il le fera et ça sera adopté
faut pas oublier là aussi il y a dans le
débat des choses inexactes qui sont dit
l'article 49 alinéa 3 serait un moyen
quasi Dict
ça n'est absolument pas le cas rappelons
tout de même que l'homme qui n'avait
rien d'un dictateur qui a utilisé le
plus l'article 49 à l'ina3 s'appelle
Michel
rocardes non si je me trompe pas bien
sûr
mais je crois que le gouvernement s'il y
a en effet il y a pas de majorité claire
étant donné que faut pas oublier on le
disait le soir des élections
législatives c'est une majorité relative
très relative qu'elle gouvernement donc
pour arriver à une majorité solide les
choses sont compliquées et tous les
moyens toutes les armes du
parlementarisme rationalisé qui ont été
inventés par le général de Gaulle et
Michel Debré dans les années 58 59
seront utilisés et
c'est peut-être les sénateurs les
républicains hier soir on entend des
Roger karucci qui a porté la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 qui est passé
à une voix qui disait mais je conseille
au gouvernement d'être prudent et
d'utiliser le 49-3 ce matin sur France
Inter Bruno Retailleau il dit il vaut
mieux un vote que les 49-3 mais il vaut
mieux le 49-3 que pas de réforme du tout
c'est aussi le message que cherche à
faire passer les sénateurs à l'air
oui on voit bien enfin les sénateurs LR
essaie de convaincre un peu les les
députés d'ailleurs c'était pas anodin
d'ailleurs d'entendre à la conclusion de
débats
au Sénat Bruno Retailleau dire on a voté
cette réforme parce que c'est notre
réforme une manière de se réapproprier
un texte et de remettre en fait le
mouvement d'anti auquel il appartient et
dont il visait la présidence en
cohérence mais voilà comme ça a été
suggéré un peu plus tôt dans la matinée
oui il y a bien des tableaux Excel oui
et bien des comptes
députés par députés et des téléphones
portables et des télés alors c'est pas
forcément le rôle du du ministre du
Travail plutôt le ministre des Relations
avec le Parlement qui fait ce travail là
mais bien sûr qu'on compte les députés
un par un et que probablement on les
appelle un par un
Bruno Retailleau il a cette expression
depuis plusieurs jours il dit pour
Elisabeth borne c'est la roulette russe
ou la Grosse Bertha c'est bien résumé
oui oui c'est assez bien résumé souvent
les hommes politiques sont excellents
commentateurs de la vie politique et des
rapports de force qu'il connaît qu'ils
connaissent bien la politique sans en
effet ce sont des rapports de force et
là on est en plein
rapport de force et l'issue bien sûr
pour le gouvernement pour l'image de la
première ministre du conflit la sortie
du conflit et tout à fait importante
mais même si l'article 49 3 est utilisé
il ne faut pas j'allais dire
surjouer l'effet de l'utilisation à long
terme de l'article 49 alinéa 3 sur sur
l'électorat et sur le pignon c'est un
article qui a déjà été utilisé qui sera
éventuellement utilisé et vous savez
pour nous observateurs ou les politiques
voilà nous connaissons toute cette
cuisine
parlementaire pour l'essentiel des
Français il regarde ça de très loin
oui mais c'est pas comme si le président
de la République n'avait pas dit au
moment de sa réélection vous allez voir
ça va se passer autrement on sera dans
une démocratie rénovée avec davantage de
concertation donc je suis d'accord avec
Pascal Perrineau le fait d'utiliser le
49-3 les gens vont pas aiguiser les
fours et faire évolution simplement mais
cette intention qu'à un moment Emmanuel
Macron a cru
utile d'exprimer dans un moment de
grande solidaire solennité et de grands
d'écoute aux Français passera la trappe
le président apprendre le métier si vous
voulez voilà
réalisme vient au président est-ce que
Manuel Macron et Elisabeth danjougro
dans ces prochaines 48 heures est-ce
qu'il joue l'avenir du quinquennat
je ne crois pas moi je ne crois pas
personnellement voilà bien sûr si la
réforme passe le second mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron retrouvera un centre
de gravité et il retrouvera l'image du
président réformateur parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y avait de la part du
président des interrogations qu'est-ce
que je vais faire et qu'elle va être le
message de mon second mandat là il
retrouvera d'une certaine manière un
centre de gravité si tout cela tourne
vinaigre en effet là les choses peuvent
devenir
préoccupantes et là on passerait à
d'autres régistes mais vous savez la
constitution d'un cinquième République
c'est une bonne constitution il y a des
armes il y a ensuite la dissolution etc
voilà on peut faire de la politique
fiction
dans ces termes on va regarder l'image
c'est le baromètre cantar Emmanuel image
d'Emmanuel Macron et quand tu applique
d'Emmanuel Macron et d'Elisabeth borne
il Patisse de cette séquence oui l'un et
l'autre sont à leur niveau les plus bas
à 30% de confiance pour le président de
la République 27% pour Isabelle borne
Emmanuel Macron a retrouvé quasiment le
niveau qu'il avait au moment de la
précédente discussion de réforme des
retraites en 2019 avant la crise la
crise covid et dans le détail on est à
41% de Français qui ne lui font pas du
tout confiance donc on voit bien qu'une
forme de crispation qui n'atteint pas le
pic qu'on avait enregistré au moment de
la crise des gilets jaunes des tas de
57% de gens qui ne diffusaient pas du
tout confiance malgré tout voilà il y a
une forme de tension dans dans le pays
c'est vrai que c'est un démarrage de
quinquennat qui s'avère peu difficile
autour de cette réforme qui était au
centre de au centre de son projet comme
la rappeler Pascal Perrineau une réforme
des retraites est évidemment une réforme
qui suscite
des réactions des réactions négatives et
ça impacte d'autant plus l'image d'un
président République dans le socle était
faible au départ non pas en raison d'une
faiblesse intrinsèque mais par exemple
le morcellement de paysage politique
Apple la difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est que de toute façon le monde
politique français est très divisé et
c'est très difficile constituer des
majorités y compris depuis l'opinion et
justement on va on va regarder le la
côte de popularité des parties
politiques après je vous fais réagir
parce qu'elle parce que ça peut paraître
assez étonnant vous allez nous le dire
Emmanuel vous allez analyser tout ça
avec nous la bonne opinion des partis
politiques c'est le rassemblement
national qui a le plus fort taux de
bonnes opinion c'est la France insoumise
qui a tôle plus bas sachant qu'Horizon
il y a beaucoup de gens qui connaissent
pas c'est un peu genre en fait si on
compare parmi les parties connues c'est
très frappant de voir que celui qui non
seulement à la meilleure opinion c'est
pas du tout anodin dans l'histoire de
notre baromètre c'est rassemblement
national avec une opinion
significativement hausse par rapport à
la précédente mesure qui date du mois de
décembre donc un parti qui est à la fois
exprimé contre la réforme des retraites
avec un objectif en la campagne de
Marine Le Pen de retour même la traite à
60 ans mais qui ne sait pas illustrer
dans le débat à l'Assemblée nationale de
la même manière que la fait la France
insoumise donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un
peu tenté le dernier ça veut dire que ça
a pas pris auprès des Français de la
stratégie et avec le niveau de rejet
c'est-à-dire de gens qui ont la une très
mauvaise image de cette formation
politique qui est bien plus élevé que
pour les autres parties donc oui on peut
dire que cette
manière de d'exprimer son opposition n'a
pas bien fonctionné parce qu'elle sur
Oui on voit que si vous voulez la France
insoumise qui cherche depuis le début à
se constituer en avant-garde du
mouvement social qui d'ailleurs a
échauffer les oreilles leurs syndicaux
de temps à autre et bien cette stratégie
du moins en termes d'impact dans
l'opinion c'est un échec c'est un échec
et que le rassemblement national qui est
une stratégie beaucoup plus sophistiquée
d'une certaine manière il est contre
mais il ne fait pas de bruit il est
contre mais il n'est pas dans les avec
les calicots etc et bien cette stratégie
d'une certaine manière le cerf est-ce
que cela veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a
de manière claire dans les oppositions
une alternative à la majorité on ne peut
pas encore franchir le pas un dernier
mot rapidement Emmanuel un point sur les
syndicats parce qu'en revanche les
syndicats eux ont trouvé dans toute
cette période une occasion d'améliorer
leur image et ce sera intéressant de
suivre et c'est un des enjeux ça ce qui
se passera si malgré la mobilisation
qu'ils ont pu obtenir il n'obtiennent
rien à ce que du coup est-ce qu'il y
aura est-ce qu'un risque de discrédit
des syndicats après une période qui leur
était plutôt favorable on suivra
évidemment tout ça
[Musique]